dude you don't look like Luke Perry I
know I / now hey the guy dies going dude
a lot of people said I look like I was
mad about you is it when he was famous
not about younger I got that yeah not
about you today today about Luke Perry
it's about Luke Perry it's about someone
else to tell you know what blue Perry my
[ __ ] so many girls well that's what
this docket is that what happened in a
stroke from doing so he's over he was
over [ __ ] yeah think what to think
about Luke Perry in his Haiti 902 1
Rosie he would walk on scene and be like
oh my oh yeah you couldn't it was nuts
so when I went back in those days when I
would walk around I would get like crazy
attention I here's what's gar you look
Perry you look more like Luke now than
back then like I'm you were younger you
don't really look like him take it he
when I was young if you look at my old
headshots I should bring in my old
headshot this has the same head yeah
it's a smaller teeth than I do who he is
that he's got them little teeth is that
one yellow one he's not playing games
he's got some baby teeth there is the
one yellow did he have a history of
drugs the history of slinging dick bro
yeah don't don't [ __ ] here he's a great
guy though I'm not what a bummer was
yeah hate to be shitty about it um you
know what I'll tell you something right
now
his stroke though 52 solid years damn
he's in the new Quinton Tino's Charles
Manson movie damn it really [ __ ] well
you know what not a bad life right you
got to celebrate his life it worked a
lot yeah it's his team badass how old
was he uh nine oh two one oh really cuz
they think about saying he was in high
school but you don't have those chops
down cyberspace has to be right
mid-twenties
52 yo if he has kids that's the bummer
all you want just look at this real
quick first history of alcohol and drugs
Howie did it yeah alcohol and drugs but
when they say history doesn't mean he's
well you mean living no so so so it was
an addict yeah well well when you're
doing a lot of cocaine for example from
what I understand and I actually know
some
who suffered a heart attack because of
this at my age you uh it's probably the
leading like when you do coke actually
you build plaque in your arteries which
I didn't realize every time though yeah
so when you're doing cocaine is a very
bad thing for your heart especially as
you get older never mind he didn't it
was just like symptoms of a stroke or
not since those things that cause it
could be alcohol and drugs but it
doesn't say anything about him doing it
yeah I don't think so that's not when
you drank a lot when you're sober though
yeah even when you're sober though so
your heart can enlarge your your
arteries get [ __ ] up so if you did a
lot of it when you were younger it can
it can affect you now that's that it was
shortens your life right it's what
happens now I don't know if that's even
better I don't know I don't I don't I
don't think we should yeah that's kind
of [ __ ] up no I don't know I was just
asking I really don't know Oh real heart
throb though yeah
real heart throb you know it's way life
good man listen this is True Grit Monday
it's true grit Monday take it easy and
and you [ __ ] walk in with your
tangerine shoes oh it's big and I pushed
you against the wall because of I didn't
do [ __ ] what you didn't let me let me
tell you something I'm fired up dude
you find me okay your foot you're making
Luke Perry's thing about you I'm not
making about me at all dude I'm sorry
about Luke but it's it's also true grit
call mr. Monday all mr. Perry you [ __ ]
calm Tom shooter call Mr Perry's used
it's inhered [ __ ] sorry
well I can't believe you didn't start
this with a salute to Diego Sanchez Oh
14 years in the Octagon 14 [ __ ] years
and still winning I got this for that
guy salute he took he took mickey girl
on the ground and [ __ ] just beat I
know but don't salute like this look
you're here like look no no here lines
back here so it's like this don't try
with my hands should do like this this
is for old guys out there you got to be
careful though because old guys know
look what's this this is for us old guys
look but if you go too high what's this
oh well that's no don't do that but I
know but that's what you just did No
that's that's black power and then
that's why Pat I know so when you salute
like this be careful okay no one leaves
my hairline it's like they're right you
got to do this
well it's also known as the mom you
don't want to do that right well with
your hairline it should be that
well don't damn I don't have a Nazi - oh
you're going down you're going down
there's this Nazi so True Grit we got
look Luke Perry was gritty but Diego
Sanchez call him a heartthrob dude
yeah heartthrob dude did you see have
you definitely didn't cuz just you don't
stay on the beat of society did you see
the Michael Jackson documentary here's
what I I read about it but you see it I
didn't but here's what pissed me off but
did you see it
I didn't but can I out before you say
before you say I want to make a critique
that I read about and I want you to tell
me what you think okay alright even
though I didn't see it okay so I'm a
little out of my lane cuz I haven't seen
it but before you give this good - yeah
what's your what where are you at on
Michael Jackson and little boys before
all this news came up um I didn't know
meaning okay so here's the other thing
what I assumed where there's smoke and
freaking toys wells fire there is
something strange about him and
sleepovers and having boys around like I
don't I'm not interested in being around
little boy I looked into my son yes but
I'm not interested there's no like dad
we're kids that I'm right yeah like if I
have sleepovers I'm involved in all the
games and stuff there's something weird
right Inc yeah but the the testimony
this this this Finding Neverland leaving
Neverland is based on two guys who are
now coming out saying they got molested
when they defended him during the trial
so I'm very confused and here's the
other reason I'm confused a good time to
do it those guys were in their 20s when
they came out yeah right is that when
they defended him at his trial I want to
find out on their twenties but so so at
your 20s what you did was you defended
at the pedophile you knew he was a
pedophile you got up on a stand under
sworn testimony and defended a pedophile
to make sure he got off yeah okay so so
what was the motive there I'm very
confused because if you weren't
protecting your privacy so I guess
you're protecting your privacy or your
emotions or whatever
and knowingly you could have put a
pedophile away but he's gonna [ __ ] other
kids apparently so what's up now I got a
huge problem while I'm your fan if
you're a kid and you can't I understand
cuz it's all [ __ ] up when you're in
your 20s and you and you defend and get
a guy off even now you come back even if
you're a father even your 20s those
tough yeah but I'm saying enjoys like I
don't know what the [ __ ] guys doing my
twenties even now it's my 35th
thirty-six birthdays yeah you're an
adult I can't I can't give you a pass
you got a pedophile off that's true but
also now you're coming back why are you
coming back yeah I mean Money Mo Money
right how much money you're gonna make a
lot that that states were three billion
dollars but how come you were on the
stand in your 20s you defended a
pedophile
you got a pedophile off with your
[ __ ] testimony as an adult now you
come back in your 40s cuz you're
quote-unquote a father and you want and
and you're some convenient money cuz
right now you're guilty no [ __ ] right no
[ __ ] but there's money now I'm out you
talking about twenty thirty million
dollars for these guys well it's a lot
of money Michael Jackson at his in his
heyday was worth one point six billion
sir yeah well there you go biggest of
all time yeah the other thing it's weird
to me is I don't know if he touched
these kids or whatever but people that
know Michael Jackson said he because he
missed out on his childhood cuz his
father's such a [ __ ] you know I think
it's probably my cat's they think that
but they'll so he just missed out on
Kitty stuff so inside he felt like he's
nine years old so he wanted to try to
hold on to that for dear life and have
that childhood so that's why I hung out
with kids yeah that's fine let me ask
you something Brian if if [ __ ] Liam
Neeson came to your house was like yo
dude I'm just a huge fan your son I'm
going on tour do you mind if he comes
with me [ __ ] out of here
punch him right in the dick [ __ ] a tit
right you attractive the parents have to
take some responsibility I would agree
with that although it's Finding
Neverland it's Michael Jackson there
with a lot of other boys a lot of other
kids you know but here's that here's
where it gets a little dicey when you
watch this documentary the detail that
these two have the detail and when they
get down to the nitty gritty and they
talk about certain things where you know
the jesse smell it right when he gave
his testimony I'm like this guy
[ __ ] yeah he's good actor I can
smell from there yeah you know my snouts
heavy dude
I haven't seen it so I got to see it did
they get together and talk details
that's my other thing
did they they've had a lot of time too
there's all a lot of video of it though
there is a lot of it I got to see it
here's where I can I think I think he's
mentally ill I think Mike Jackson's
mentally yeah mentio on them beats no
but I think you know thea when it comes
to children I look at look at this time
what are you doing with the old here's
the thing be they do they play a thing
on there were the little dudes and I'm
sorry from my voice on it sounds sexy
great listeners out there yeah a lot of
sudden hey smooth jazz 97 cheering for
the fight so they play a video where
they're on a private jet because the key
bought the kid all around with them and
there's the parents aren't on there so
just one kid he brought it round with me
just one well there's two but he'd
bounce from kid to kid but [ __ ] weird
it's super weird he wouldn't give
interviews we let this little kid
interview him and he can tell the
infatuation and the love he has with
this kid and him half together it's
awkward as [ __ ]
he's like Billy you know you're my
favorite you know when we shot that
Pepsi commercial that's my favorite and
he's the kids like oh thank you he's
like well what's your favorite part
about going to Hawaii being on touring
of spending it with you Billy being with
you Billy it's like well that's what
nightmares are made of
now is he just [ __ ] up in the head or
was he actually sucking kids off I don't
think I don't like either one I don't
like it's so awkward I don't blame the
parents because if [ __ ] you're gonna
put Elton John knocked on my door with
his entire on Michael Jackson we have to
go any further than the bill not take
Michael Jackson or knocking at door to
these dead but if Elton John's still
alive
name it the most famous person well
whose most famous person or I know if
they knock on my door you ain't taking
you not hanging out with my kid bro
right unless it's a daddy date where the
your kids same ages mind you and you
want to kick it so here's my question
this came up all of this came up in a
trial two trials right and he got off is
there any evidence all of this came up
in trials and those what about in his
defense how old were they I need to find
out how old these two guys were when
they
defended him I need to find that out
also there's no like legit evidence it's
all hearsay
it's also in case with these here's the
other thing the biggest thing we have is
that remark that kid described his dick
first of all if I was eight years old
and you asked me what this dude's dick
look like I mean I'm sure I could give
you a rough estimate you know I'm saying
those little [ __ ] could dance though
in this documentary they're like four
and seven they can [ __ ] move I also
you know I'm always like whenever it's a
it's a documentary I'm always like this
like it like making a murder or anything
else you're seeing you're seeing one
side of something I don't know I do I
believe do I think it's weird
yes do I believe he could have done it
yes but this is this you know so sweaty
there were 30 36 there 36 and 40 now so
when was he accused mine was that trial
team the first via 2013 lawsuits later
in the documentary to talk about the
alleged loose started when he was seven
safe trick when he's 10
both had previously told authorities
that there have been no abuse with
Robson testifying Jackson defense to I'm
five
okay so what's 2005 so would be 14 years
ago Brian yeah okay so 14 he's 35 now
yeah during the 20s yeah mid-20s you're
21 and you're 20 and you're 25 [ __ ] I'm
sorry
[ __ ] you sounds a little weird [ __ ]
so you so you as an adult you know this
dude if it's true then you know this guy
molest children and and that we know one
thing about people in the last children
they have a track record they don't stop
these priests unless 200 kids so you
know there's a track record it's not
like that was always my thing with Woody
Allen there's only one story she was
seven she doesn't remember her mom told
her I can't go with that but with a with
a with a Tom molester there is a [ __ ]
litany of people there's all hope
there's a whole list of people there's a
literature you know that the list of
people Jackson though huh what would
actually these two guys below there's
way more than two guys no I don't think
so there's a shitload of claims against
them but again again I and I don't agree
with it either skeptical hip wise we
don't know but listen what Jackson's
family says they said no
there's no way it can be Wade Robinson
not the same guy that I knew they must
have gotten the names wrong said his
brother Wade was the most adamant
personally came to two on five in the
trial he was their first defense witness
he was the star witness he was adamant
that nothing ever happens in terrestrial
to the in in society
now it's guilty to proven innocent so
everyone goes oh there it is but also
now documentaries can paint the
narrative and get you on and get you
rich although with our Kelly that
definitely that not but I'm saying this
this is theirs
I'm just being skeptical because there's
real money involved for these guys it's
Fame money a book you're talking about
millions of dollars and you guys were 21
and 25 what it was and you got you
willingly you and adamantly defended a
child molester if that's true [ __ ] you I
don't have any time for that man I'm
sorry man you're an adult and here's
here's a little another nugget for your
Kalin Robinson whose allegation they say
have coincided with financial problem
okay there you go come on what a
surprise what a surprise
Kat you're young as [ __ ] what do you
think of Michael Jackson well I know
he's an amazing performer because
growing up I knew about it but I didn't
know as many details as everything is
coming out now does that mic not work -
oh yes let me ask you this yeah if he
gets to convey that say the court for
even though he's passed away he's
convicted
would you still listen to his music
what's that ticket would you if he was
convicted of molesting a little kids
like actually convicted let's say we had
a r.kelly videotape of Michael Jackson
yeah would you still does it change what
he did musically I mean not really
because it's two separate things right I
mean uh that's a tough one why cuz you
should enjoy a Woody Allen movie yeah
because I don't think he did it I don't
know why my voice squeak I mean he's one
of the greatest filmmakers I think he is
yeah yeah but let's say he actually did
rape that young girl and then married
his yeah daughter which is super strange
yeah
so it doesn't mean he's not a great
artist that's why I'm saying can't you
separate the art from the well that's
always been the question of course you
can but but but but the bottom eyes I
would try to me I know Brian but the
current culture says you can't because
our Kelly office music has been taken
down off iTunes but I mean doubt you
were abusing kids and you listened yeah
I would listen to it differently I
probably knowing me okay so did this is
how I am
once the secret alias only certain once
the CD stuff came out about football
right like the NFL and I was and I and I
started I didn't watch football the same
way because every time guys would get
hit I would think about it but in
fighting it kind of it kind of it kind
of [ __ ] up the game for me I guess
then you watch fighting yeah okay that
does well I mean the same thing you
watch Bob I haven't thought about it as
much but I fight if I start thinking
about it big like it'll it'll color the
way I think you pick and choose yeah you
want the yeah yeah yeah yeah no but so
if footballs isn't doesn't mean he's not
means he's got a deep goes on that
really gene kicks in I'm [ __ ] he's
one of the greatest of all time my body
can't help but Moo oh yeah baby hippo is
over this and and I've read a lot about
I think I think he's mentally ill yes
yes dude how about I Drive by his crib
on my way to work when they were taping
Hearst when their time I script named it
I go that road sounds so familiar kept
going then it hit me like that mother
Havenhurst
that's the road I [ __ ] take and
that's where it never landed no never
lands in Santa Barbara
Havenhurst is in Encino and that's right
that's that's the road I take together
[ __ ] okay just stop took picture Wow
yeah I don't know a bunch of cars but I
got I got real skeptical hippos with
these [ __ ] guys you know and I and I
got no respect for the fact that you
didn't stand up when you could have and
you could have taken a child molester
out if this is true if it was true yeah
the star witness
you were the star went you were the key
you were adamant at 25 or 21 whatever
you were old enough to know better
do not think we should throw therefore
if he did touch those kids throw the
parents in jail Wow
good luck to you know you
can only it most of us miss by
star-struck they were probably okay
entrusting those people most people
don't even think that you know it's the
first thing I think of as soon as anyone
goes dude something bout your kid I'm
like what the [ __ ] you talking about
dude so so but sometimes you're like you
can't get away with it today like if if
name any famous artists name any famous
actor if they rank if George Clooney was
going around town with another random
boy he's like he's just my friend dude
we would all roast the [ __ ] out of
course you couldn't do it today but you
know you know let me here's what it is
with me whenever I hear an accusation
about somebody like a politician doing
something or my first reaction is to
defend them because I don't think that
way
and I always think to myself why would
you do that like why would I think the
worst in people but see that's smart
so so so gonna get another example when
the Iraq war came out and all the
architects of the Iraq war I got in real
arguments with like people like like my
buddy Will Arnett Bradley Cooper and
stuff like that and they were like this
is ladies oh yeah but it's true I was
thinking about that because it was it
kind of like it kind of caused tension
because they were I don't why I brought
think I thought because we were in a
group of people we had was really
passionate everybody was followed that
we were following it because when in
2003 the 2001-2002 before they invaded
when it was coming up to it I said to
myself this might be a good idea to take
out the fourth largest army the biggest
threat to you know the United States and
all that stuff and they were really
skeptical of the motives of the people
in power there in the power there and
they're in the money and for me I was
like that's how they think cuz I don't
think that way and I look back on it I
was wrong they were right I was they
were right yeah and sometimes it's
better to think the worse than people in
apologize when it comes up to and goes
dude let me do this for you this for you
you don't automatically doing I don't
you you you say to me I do all the time
you go he's not your friend Brian though
let you do that to me all the time cuz
I'll be like I just trust that I don't
I'm naive that way I really am and I
always have in my dad it's probably
laugh at me about that my brother-in-law
you belie quality in you I don't know
you get burned you know is this was you
burned
anyway drops and look at his [ __ ] ass
now today what he had that the fire
outfits though I don't think Wade's gay
the guy on the left from the jump was uh
gayland
from the jump I just I just have
skeptical hippo eyes again again man you
got a chocolate up the pants let's say
[ __ ] Quentin Tarantino's like dude
I'm a huge fan of Tiger I want to take
her in Hawaii dude guess what [ __ ] off
let me goes alright you can come with
them all right let's go Hawaii this is
weird but let's say I do and when we get
to the hotel yours dude I got a suite in
mind if Tiger stays with me stay down
there is that what happened yep I'd go
listen Quentin I'm gonna pop is that
really what happened heads like is it
that's what happened and then the mom
goes well why can I stay with him you
know the suite we got your room down
there can't get your room next to
Michael because the Michael wanted to
stay with those kids cuz the little boy
you know Michael's the end-all be-all so
they're like yeah I want stay the night
with him yeah so he's the night with him
I find that very weird so now I'm torn
the guys regulation regulation of him
like teach them how to masturbate and
stuff it's somewhat it would be hard to
make up but they've had enough time
where you could definitely do it also
why else I've skipped with hip eyes
because Wade let's be honest you loser
so you needed money yeah but here's the
thing is you loser
or you just traumatize cuz the biggest
pop culture I kind of all time was
sucking them off yeah well jumpin that
will destroy a human being when you get
molested as a child you you can be
destroyed for it causes such depress and
such debilitating and I know issues this
is why there are three people walking
this earth who can watch my kid his mom
his grandma is grandpa that is it yep we
got a new nanny you know I did first
time she took him out myself you know
what I did I spied on that [ __ ] yeah
followed her dude and followed it that's
how I roll man an hour took an hour of
work and note-taking worth it and hiding
was like the mo may be worth it maybe
there's three try stuff like a tree yep
because guess what if that if they do do
something that kid his life is [ __ ]
man I agree with super fun tree so sir
that's zero chance the first thing my
mother-in-law said
no older boys to babysit your kid no
matter what no I was like I know that
I'm [ __ ] I'm like I'm like a of
course not no boys yeah how about that
no boys no no no hate to tell you there
there's a gender difference there's why
I just there's why there's where I
[ __ ] I'm writing that down
that's my new I got I got a whole thing
on this that's where I'm [ __ ]
discriminating yeah
babysitters yeah babysitter's my son
comes me out for teens like dad I got
something to tell you
like what he's like we're a me that
really attractive babies that I'm like
yeah he's like she sucked me off of like
let's go get a bear dude that's [ __ ]
awesome
yeah this bump I've jacked off many
times today is it good all right let's
get out of here now if I had a daughter
and she's like listen yeah build the
babysitter
yeah molested me she's locked yeah we're
not getting well I am no we will hire a
therapist I have a friend who went
through this and he his son was having
major problems and and and some was
older and he said finally said this
guy's smart and he goes he said to his
son he goes he just he was like
something's wrong here I said did you
ever suffer any sexual abuse and it was
you know kids crying kids started crying
and it was when he was younger the older
boy and older boy older boy a lot of
times family members family this was an
older boy under it was it was I don't
want to give too much away I want to
respect his privacy but it was them it
was a very innocent it was a be a very
innocent thing to do and you wouldn't
think cuz people would be supervised but
this kid had a way was he a lifeguard no
so so what happened was it happened and
over the yeah and and and the the mother
knew kept it from the father tried to
like and nobody talked about it and all
that stuff and it's it's it is something
that has to be dealt with but it can
cause major fall my kidding me dude
major [ __ ] dam cheney overran fondled
probably no thank god yeah it all
depends I mean I don't feel confined
also I was fine I feel like cow be the
worst kid to try to follow because I
feel like you're feisty
oh yeah I also have like a gang of
uncles who just like would not put up
with their fit maize also cute I know I
was a cutie pie as a kid but I'm a
Chatty Cathy so you touch my dick
everybody's fine now well that's what I
it's a moment I leave that room ongoing
guess what just happy that sorry I did
even though even if Michael Jackson I
dude pinky swear cuz my career will be
over if you tell everyone about this
Mike dude no problem as soon as I get
out bike I go to my brother Mike guess
what happened Jackson just sucked me off
dude well I'd call my friend bro you'll
never believe what just happened you
know what happened to me right in camp I
get I get fought with my favorite store
camp counselors I know it's dark it's
one of my favorite stands and then I
talked to my other buddy what set this
up for the people who miss this story
well they're sold on jr. yeah yeah there
that's it how old and there there are
two incidents but I don't mean to make
light of those now there'll it's the
only thing you can well for me look he's
turned out great
yeah and by the way I but but the
difference between but see there's a
difference between being in a position
where you have to do it all the time
because they manipulate your brain how
they where they rape you
yeah and there's difference being that
and being farmer but and there's also a
black guy going into it well that's true
so I wake up and the guys fiddling with
my Willie and I'm like [ __ ] boys camp so
we would be passing broke camp so go
away on canoe trips summer camp yes yeah
so we rinse our camp you go out canoe
trips and there's one camp Council yeah
and I remember we hold we were
skinny-dipping and he he reached under
my friend we were [ __ ] we were probably
like 11 12
okay you know older and old enough again
I don't remember still and he reached
under the guy reached under my buddy's
dong have said there's a bone right
there my buddy stand naked we were like
we're wet from the lake sure IRA he
reached under and pointed to his taint
any bullet there's a there's a bone
right there he was telling a story
marathon that guy reached with a hook
and just under and say you're digging
mouth here and he reached yeah and
increased like here's his dong any
recent much my dad goes right there and
I went that's weird like a first red
flag weird
no but I remember talking I mean we were
saying we were all he was back John
20 and Donnie what how's the guy
touching the kids oh he was probably he
I think if I look back on it he's play
35 you know I don't know him he had a
beard he had a beard Holly I'm by the
way good big difference not not a not a
mean manipulative guy he was a very
sweet man
yeah couldn't catch a bomber threw a
ball at his face anyone like this with
like he was a very he and he loved he
was he was a loving he just loved little
boys not sure I keep going like you
noticed you know the the unassuming soft
pedophile as it were right pudgy and all
that sure and I'm not making light of
this when I tell a circus I know people
suffering real [ __ ] the Jews and I did
this I don't consider them no idea but
for me what happened was I had friends I
was talking to and all my friends
started going this is where we're thing
by the way I didn't say this on GRE but
my other body I think back on this my
other buddy says oh I already got
molested by this other dude same kid who
was an ex-military guy in our camp and
he was still there but we didn't think
back then what is this the 70s yeah I
didn't think about we until today I was
like he did but I was fried egg I never
did anything to me so I always was
skeptical about that I was like did he I
don't know about that hmm
but then again he's a camp counselor
he's with boys all the time that's what
he does
red-flagged right so there was always
his weird [ __ ] so I wake up and he's got
his hand I'm we're basically we all
sleep together like in Hindi tents you
know but it was like I don't know maybe
three to attend to I remember but I
remember waking up and that guy had his
hand down my pants on white with tighty
whiteys I'm in the morning is who now
seven sure and I'm and I'm feeling it
and I remember waking up going it just
seemed like it was no hold on and in
under them yes yes damn under yeah yeah
but I swear to God I sort of got it's
funny when you're a kid you you it
doesn't register like I didn't register
that it was weird like I did I did then
I was like cuz I did that I used to do
that you know I mean when you wake up
and you go here you're playing with you
little Willy yeah during the show so it
felt like that and I was like this is we
so I go to my buddy and I go to my buddy
Donna hi girl
hey he touched my dick this morning he
can't was playing with it and I think I
pretend I had to go to the bathroom or
something which I do that probably pee
and he goes he sucked my god right so I
go I meant now cuz I'm slow but you're
you're a boy I put it all together it's
a whitey son and then I said to my buddy
my mother but yeah he tried to put his
finger there whatever and I go I [ __ ]
I I went all right cool marched well I
remember I remember I was like this
doesn't make sense and then I'm thinking
about it your snare I take my name off
the next trip the next camping trip you
used to sign up played out of the night
and sit out on the next trip right so he
gives me because I saw you were
scratched your name off what happened
what happened touch and then then my
friend I said I think I want to tell on
him and my friend Donny said my friend
Donny goes I feel like I'm protecting
his he goes don't do it don't don't
don't say anything don't say any man
come on and he was like don't and this
is what happens this is what happens you
don't want as a kid you don't want to
make a thing about it because it you
don't understand it you don't have
context for it but I was like your boy
my mother came oh yeah or for like you
know parent there when I'm telling I
marched right to my mother go hey guess
what
that guy did this that and the other
thing he also did this they brought all
of us in all of us told I remember I
never forgot the owner the camp said now
I'm gonna ask you some questions I don't
want to get emotional about it did he
put his mouth here he asked me all kinds
of question I said no but he did it to
Donny and they brought Donnie and Donnie
was like [ __ ] you know he was
sensitive I wasn't dude I wasn't your
socio but I'm not a sensitive young dead
behind yeah you know I am I'm not
sensitive I don't know why I'm just not
that my other friend was and I said
honey was crying yeah and I wasn't and
again maybe I would have been but I
wasn't raped and there's a difference
like I said some kids you can't come
back from that especially but it's a
priest or or somebody that that is a
pillar of the baby so what they you
don't know what adjourn would they do to
the camp Oh oh I that's was the
seventies Baba you know what they told
he was made
he was married you know that his wife
said because my mother said this to me
his wife said oh god he's up to that
again oh my god and she was the arts and
crafts teams in the seventies this is
why this this is why this me to thing is
a good thing because it's raising
awareness for people who really have
been traumatizing abused and so what
happened was he goes um and then they
just he just was moved on back then
there's no database there's no like you
know he was just moved on I don't know
what happened that's so critical as a as
a because you didn't read about this
stuff as a boy as a mother as you didn't
think it was that big a deal because it
was just a creepy guy from a different
but you know what I mean you do because
we back then what did you you know how
kids getting abducted would you care
about that stuff would your death
because if I always came home from
school went dad my teacher my teacher
mr. Blake yes my dick my dad once what's
his name
yeah what a Martin my there was overseas
and I bet and then you asked me for the
first time I just never think about this
I bet you my mother never told him and I
bet you he still doesn't know he knows
now yeah I bet you my mom never told him
but because that would serve no good
but back then by the way can you imagine
the lawsuit now that was never even
brought up back then no one sued back
then now we're all suab no no you didn't
sue you didn't know about child
abduction you didn't know about
perversion you didn't none of this stuff
was talked about I'm old enough to
remember this none of this stuff was and
it was it was what he was considered to
be was the same as a peeping tom or a
flasher or that that's kind of everybody
all those weirdos were put in the
context my sister came home and this guy
asked her to touch his dick and said
it's a red balloon and she I remember we
had to talk about in the family this was
in Greece went over there back in 76 or
something so again these were things
that you you didn't hear about the
stories of child abduction of child
rewound you heard about a creep who
jerked off in a car you never had any
problems chin no close calls I don't
think so
so we don't remember stuff like jonathon
height you know the social the social
psychology was on Rogan he said back in
the day kids were allowed to walk to
school they were allowed to do
everything on their own they could play
and everything else then in the 80s the
reason there were some high-profile
child abductions and the details came
out like John Wayne Gacy about what he
did Ted Bundy and all of a sudden we
found out that there were very evil
people out there who got off on killing
torturing and raping women children and
and Jonathan Hyde does a really good job
of showing this when kids start showing
up on milk cartons you had a generation
of helicopter parents oh yeah and all of
a sudden parents like you I'm Gil like
me we don't let our kids go to the store
we don't let our kids walk home we don't
let our kids ever be alone and
unsupervised and and and what is done is
its created a lot of anxiety in children
a lot of a lack of independence it's
created kids who always have somebody
watching over them so they don't settle
things on their own what they do is they
go to the authority figure and it's
caused a lot of damage and we'll do live
in though how many how many kids are
abducted by strangers a year
couldn't tell you number I have no idea
100 very very few it's very good [ __ ]
rare god damn right it's good I've
always been very loose Iggy's always
been very rare but you pay a price too
for being having a how either way though
well listen either way listen it's our
worst nightmare it's every parent's
worst nightmare you never had any close
calls cows being molested
no I was super sheltered already shelter
yeah a lot more pins when you go uh know
kind of like helicopter parents where my
parents didn't want me going out walking
around by myself so I'd always have a
cousin or uncle or I feel like where the
girl it's different yes it is like with
my son if he's big and again it's a
sexist thing that's the world we live in
not a little girl she's a little button
cute you know like Judas [ __ ] you're not
gonna let her just roam by herself and
play by herself with a boy it's like
yeah yeah yeah no depends it was a
different world as I tell that story I
did all that comes back as I start
thinking about how different that the
world was back even the nine Muses
yeah I never really had any close calls
I was a cute kid - no one came by there
most of the time kids those kids deal
with perverts who are going to do
something like you know pulled exposed
themselves or you know
it's it's but these priests and you know
that now that that's a real problem dude
remember when people with like flashers
I married be like on the news people
that run by and like flash beat down
yeah it easy take it easy hey cops let's
focus on something yeah they do a guy
who flashes his dick to the cars it's
not an outsider the problem is that
sometimes flashers and peeping tom
sometimes that's a ladder to deeper more
[ __ ] up starts with the beeps yeah
starts with a teenager that he did the
dream what Brian question if you've like
found out who that guy was today would
you want him in trouble or what you
would be my guest
no would you want him in jail would you
be like he was a long time ago I'm gonna
forget about it no I I would probably I
don't know if he was the kind of guy who
I don't I can't have a guy like that out
there yeah if the first thing I would do
is there I would say if he was in a
retirement home or yes if he's around
kids still feels like a TV mom taking
his down because because I may not have
been traumatized but I don't know what
he's done though there no no I can't
have you I can't have you touching kid
but how old would he be now 80 something
85 yeah he was 30 yeah seven yeah he'd
be old he might be dead
he wasn't healthy he was kind of you
know not a very it wasn't you know
though sometimes was a big heavy-duty
liver well well look at these these look
at these [ __ ] Cardinals and priests
who have a history and they're living in
the Vatican they're protected that's so
dark [ __ ] you man it's just compromised
the church it's um you know that to me
the ultimately that did this this with
children is you know because you I have
kids it's the ultimate to me I it's it's
the ultimate evil man it's a special
kind of [ __ ] up you know I wish I
could freeze my son right not three
years old he's so [ __ ] cute just wish
you could freeze down the greatest I
know dude believe me I I my son seven I
still I just can't get enough but man
that age three oh so cute oh the
greatest hilarious cuz they're figuring
[ __ ] out you know my son now at seven my
sense of humor that kid's gonna be a
comedian
like I love it he's just a and he's got
all my liabilities and all my strengths
I can just watch him do [ __ ] dude I'll
switch subjects from kids to get
molested I drank a bunch of juice
yesterday looks like real green juice oh
boy
bro oh you got a little sick E you have
a little sick I don't know what's going
on I feel fine that's right here yeah
feels like I'm losing my voice yeah
you're getting that spectra chest cold
that feels fine I'm putting my family a
frank grillo all my boys I feel fine
though
yeah maybe yeah hopefully not you're a
busy day and night um but I drank a
bunch of green juice dude when I say I
had diarrhea would be an understatement
yeah it was even diarrhea it was just
brown water yep I did that I did too it
was it I was like nothing I've ever
experienced I did 2 liters that decided
to play tennis oh wow yeah I looked at
my buddies you may go I think I shat
shat myself so I'm gonna have to stop
now because I my underwear it looked
like C I didn't know what to do I didn't
know what to do seaweed in my poop in my
panties chocolate milk you had chocolate
milk I had to see what I look like
I made poo poo Steve is very strange
seaweed poo poo yeah yeah I don't know
man yeah that'll squirt right at you
here your rum pour in oh my ass is
chapped you know the sphincter is the
most incredible muscle in the body
because it can hold water and it can
hold solid and it can kind of tell the
difference how about that and gasps I'm
sorry it holds water solid matter and
gas and can kind of like and knows when
and what it is and can let it's very
amazing your old snake there and I want
to get up in there and I want to take a
look at make sure everything's all right
now listen me you're my friend I'm gonna
take these two double really get I'm
gonna get there I'm gonna start working
a little bit I'm gonna bite down a belt
I don't want any follow lip out of you
use its True Grit Monday it's true grit
Monday any any observations on the
fights I know I'm sure you probably
broke them down already and they're
doing after the Sun rose but what he got
what you do know what do you got oh no
no I have all the energy for this I want
to see Robbie Lawler and Ben Askren for
you I'll do it again I mean I think
Robbie longer beats him maybe yeah we
don't know
just the biggest baddest [ __ ] on
the planet so it's been asking though
and also that Bulldog choke had been
real trouble if they didn't stop it
really yes really yes there's there's
not arguing you can't go over I'll be
longer would just beat the [ __ ] I'm
Robbie Lawler was in a lot of trouble
it's a lot of trouble yeah they're both
in trouble yeah
so the rematch makes sense yeah John
Jones is just too good always just too
good
how about when he's on his knees just
pounding on him like that how good no
you're missing the newsmen the [ __ ] a
copy [ __ ] dismantled was just like just
I'm gonna get in your face and who's
gonna be with reshma amazing yeah it's
fine Colby coming enough that he can't
wait he hates Colby coming coming I hate
each other what do you think of that
what do you call them news van who's
been bigger
he's just stronger you do the same thing
yes think uzum is better yeah and you
listen has that sick cardio just doesn't
get I both do so scold me though yeah
call is crazy that way it'll be
interesting I'm looking for that dude
how was you tall [ __ ] amazing those
crowds are amazing sold out why one ad
they wanted to add a third show and
would you tell me and I said absolutely
not absolutely not I cuz I'm the 8,000
feet up and I tried Denver once and I'd
they get you Oh it'll get you prepared
at sea level doing three shows a night
it's tough work it's tough work and I
don't want to do it I'm not interested
but it was amazing [ __ ] but snowed
the whole time which is why I live in
Southern California hate snow yeah yep
dump dumping yep when did some
bodybuilding that's my new thing that I
mentioned that no I'm not doing this all
this crazy like this what you should
then put some on edge where it says dick
in it man I'm doing I'm doing [ __ ]
I'm doing isolating my muscle the belly
of the muscle not the tenants and I'm
gonna get thick I'm doing a bodybuilding
chess that's what I'm doing worked out
with my boy Justin DS who helped me out
he's a [ __ ] high level coach and he
was just like here you go
just loosen him on chest where's a
better chest you're been asking go well
she bends just yeah well his body looks
like it's so funny for her guys been
wrestling training his whole life and he
looks some guys just genetically looks
somewhat soft hilarious he just does
ultimate dad one rule now Robbie Lawler
body looks better than ever I know look
at that dad bot I'm a powerful DEP well
he just having daddy buy the best
grappler in the world but what I was so
ridiculous right but I mean that's it
that bit but Robbie Lawler looks better
than ever
Italy great what is it what is it about
a dude like that in his brain that he
just loves to fight that much a
stone-cold killer
just the ultimate [ __ ] badass Oh quite
some time he's been doing it forever
since he was 17
he's just that's he's just another day
but Ben Askren was talking about it was
so interesting he said you when you
become when people say you know when I
was talking about wrestling d1 or going
to American University you woulda guys
well like I technically I went to
American and I was gonna try out for the
team but I had beaten their starter in
my weight classes in high school but
when you talk about this level of
wrestling like with our University of
Arizona where everybody was undefeated
in high school everybody's an all-star
and then those guys wrestle each other
he's just metal sharpening metal and
that kind of training I would imagine
that kind of d1 wrestling training is
way harder than a level a hard one
behind the correlation between you never
wrestling in college it's been a scream
I'm saying only even even the mat fact
that I talk about wrestling is like it's
not the same thing as I just shut up
about it because that level of wrestling
and that kind of dedication is there's
d1 wrestling and then there's d1
wrestling right and I feel like either I
did I'm saying I'm saying that's why I
that's why when I even you make in your
sense my point is my voice will there
it's my point there's no point there's
no jumping point but I've just at times
I've been like well I went to a d1
school right like oh we good in high
school like it's like you didn't go you
didn't wrestle there there's no there's
no story well the story is you never
really applied myself over so it's d1
wrestling the the regimen that you go
through in college Hart much harder than
what do you want football just there
physically just different
physically it's different it's not it's
not you wouldn't say it's physically
more demanding though I mean stuff I'm
not wrestling's as tough as it gets you
know this dude yeah we just do me a
favor moving forward they'll never
compare your wrestling spirit in college
which doesn't exist right to basket
really so I can't do that it's so
strange
no but I was also there big way more so
I did some takedowns know I did some
advanced human wrestling call Sam at
guys is there a difference guys like
when I was in college well there's d1
schools and then there's d1 schools you
know what I'm saying everybody let's go
to current events oh yeah I'm next night
if I ever meet Penn I'm gonna go I
wrestle - that's him right there so
Walmart is getting a lot of backlash
because they announced that they're
officially gonna stop hiring people as
people greeters I wash it well here's
the thing though you're seeing
have you seen Brandon careful I did
bring up some of the hallmark readers I
wanna thank you
Walmart don't say it out a Walmart they
don't look like Robbie Lawler is what
you're saying no or been asking okay
well just be here's your call be cool
bro be [ __ ] cool Brian the clock King
cool bro here's the thing though Walmart
greeters Walmart greeters and then guys
you put away your groceries are the same
guy because I went to the grocery store
I went to Ralph's yesterday and the guy
put him away was talking really loud and
asking questions everyone get hurt I
thought well Jesus dude he wouldn't he
look norm until hand if you look normal
yeah and you know I and then the biggest
kind of red flag is I bought some brandy
McCool story bread's going on bottom
milks going on top of bread Wow okay
ders are people who are handicapped and
mentally handicapped or old yeah usually
it's some greeters are either elderly or
they have some sort of disability Oh
gives them a job to keep a man we
actually guys dude I did get look those
guys are dope
I thought that's fake dude I did get
molested kind of there's a kid talking
about greeters well it's kind of a
greeter there was um there's a kid
there's a kid with Down syndrome at CU
and he worked in dau ward yeah and he
would always be in sweats
I remember they asked him to carry the
towels and he stuffed all the towels in
his pants and they're like shirt and
they're like well no dude he can't do
that today the towels anyways he had
Down syndrome had a twin but whenever
whenever we would get Gatorade or shakes
he would say he would always refill the
cups and he'd always stand behind me and
rub the small my back in my ass and I
thought he's doing it to everybody and
then when we're in the locker room they
go damn did you hear about I forget his
name and I go yeah dude why see always
touching us like why the [ __ ] so handsy
man does he always touch your butt and
like your lower back when you're gonna
drinks and was all no no like what
didn't touch everyone I thought you you
thought we were cool if you were a
favorite because he had the damn yeah
well yeah I thought we were cool because
he had downs he could just do whatever
he wants he's and the guy's like [ __ ] no
dude you got like not because of me but
he did lose his job
oh I know cuz he can't be I'm sure you
touch the wrong kid can't be petting
your butt none every day every day I get
Gary and he just pop up very sneaky and
start rubbing my ass I was like this is
how this is live dude I won't play
Division one football you gotta have the
kid with Down's rub your ass yeah I
thought he was doing it to everyone
yeah you got a nice back and a nice ass
I brought but he was kind of a greeter
he the reason why right he's like the
greed of doll War he like oh that's cool
man yeah he was like 40 well I like him
I think they should have greeters
because it gives people who are lonely
or old or nothing to do yeah man and
especially people who are handicapped
like if I had a candy kept child you
know and they were in a wheelchair or
whatever I want them to be around people
yeah we wanted to have a purpose yeah
here's the thing I don't know they
shouldn't be the shimmy bag in the
groceries though he's like he took he
took like my my produce and put it on
top of the chicken haven't they took you
should have a degree man yeah your your
anti a-- handicap oh my god no bro oh
yeah you know why don't you go fire
those bedrooms greeters your brainers
yes to the your it so your bread isn't
as my account well so that your bread
isn't squishy I guess we'll have to fire
all the [ __ ] people who are mentally
disabled and they're not allowed to bag
or maybe just the Brendan's bread can be
[ __ ] unscrew maybe no one at Ralph's
listen you know what I'm a bad person
yeah why here hey I used to work at a
grocery store and I got fired and I
stood back to groceries and there's a
kid with Down syndrome
it was bagging him too and I would I
hated my life and my job there so I
grabbed all the new magazines and candy
and donuts just sit in the bathroom
Crump up the magazines you and just like
mess around and they're passing the
minutes and the hours here and then I
put the magazines back and finally that
a meeting and they were like hey whoever
the [ __ ] is ruined the mags and
everything you know this is a problem
someone inside it's an inside job doing
this and I thought the easy victim would
be the kid with Down's oh no I think
it's Gerald you ha you had just out of
yourself as a terrible person no but oh
my god I'm afraid I can't do this
podcast anymore oh my god the fall guy
was Friday but I that sick thing is that
was that you know he wouldn't get nobody
sucking in trouble he had a Hall Pass
you [ __ ] use a way better employee
than me so blame Jerry
I blame Jerry he just he has some
strikes dude I've no more stress you had
no more I don't give me so you when it
came down oh you when it came down to it
I need this job that guy is mentally
disabled can go home in front of the TV
enjoy this you gotta get out of here kid
you're through a mentally disabled Hey
but no it was all nah man Jay wouldn't
do that [ __ ] down it was the fact I mean
a bad person who's the poster boy of
though you've got
- does it mentally disabled people fired
one for no I just got fired yeah I don't
believe it didn't snitch on here man you
got you had two people fired now you
want them all fired no right it is
saying they shouldn't be bagging
groceries oh my god he is Brett you
heard it here first
Brendan Schaub is the enemy to everyone
with towns I got fired though dude
Gerry's you're the bogeyman Gerry's good
dude
that's the moral this story is Gerry's
good if you have downs watch out for
Brendan he'll get you fired from the one
job you have I think you know what this
kid with Dyer I think Jerry here's the
thing there's a blame Tara's a good
t-shirt like this here's the thing is in
middle school we had this kid with
Down's Enki we called him big red he's a
redhead with Down's checked all the
boxes and he was so strong and fast and
I always picked him first he was fastest
she was fast I picked him first I don't
believe you
dude I swear see they try to get them
first you're in a hole I wanna kick
stuff out I do I pee now you're lying
every time they got a guy go big red of
course you want big red because you know
you want to I don't want to hurt his
feeling he'll because he could [ __ ]
tack like Bobby Boucher okay he's way
strong in everyone right say how'd that
blow up ass like they have yeah see you
chose him you know let's move on well I
can't move on now I did cry in a corner
I'll be right back yeah next one next
one
so Skechers released in an ad a throwing
shade at Nike about there's their
sneaker breaking and it's if you scroll
down it says just bluest Skechers we
won't split on you then great
Wow but you're also Skechers okay no
one's wearing those who knows if they
blow out or not no one's rockin Skechers
on the bball court no could you see Zion
[ __ ] blow it's you out yeah yeah yeah
dude you haven't been watching the NFL
Combine I watched I bring up Metcalfe I
saw him that was stupid you did see him
you don't need to bring that I love
watch them and then watch it again
how many times it he he's just how tall
is he 1.9 body-fat the draft for 340 I
mean it's 230 pounds 6-3
I'll stay 1.8 percent body fat which is
a lie but let's just keep doing it what
is his start crying after an aborted
game has a life-changing moment god damn
4 3 3 230 pound 3 stop no I'm I'm
looking at stands right now you I saw
two or three Scouts look at their
stopwatch and show others chaps as if
did you get that dick am I reading this
way it's bad man I would look into the
camera I just say I'm Batman
I might throw up the deuce oh my god
dude it's Jordan 30 pounds oh my god for
three and four three eight that's insane
a 4-4-2 so that's faster than julio
jones that's faster than Beckham jr.
maybe a ten but he's 230 and that's a
wide receiver sir these six - I'm sorry
six - this is just physical definitely
won the first round that's 225 I mean
sighs did you do it my seven how many is
he doing here twenty-six
there's a Samoan gigas 260 times it's
never good if you're that good at it a
guy who really killed it never makes a
man thought okay he's that gonna bench
just usually short stubby with no big
chest it's like the guys who do like 60
times a 53 times yeah then it fells like
oh that's me I got a 4.5 inch we're a
what 40 and a half 47 reps
25 definite not 47 okay I guess it's a
cord of [ __ ] power the guy's absolute
freakazoid oh my god think girls want to
have his babies yeah I got to start
training Oh tell that Ben Askren story
yeah so I was 21 school carry on they
had d1 wrestling where I went to college
but I had wrestle in high school weed
and I thought about was laying breath
and I would have had to have made the
team so speaking of molesters um Ian
McKellan was on a podcast talking about
God Brian singer and Kevin Spacey saying
that they were closeted when they were
abusing kids and German scumbags yes and
that he suggested if they were out that
abuse wouldn't of had happened he later
recanted and apologized for what he said
so he's saying if Brian singer and Kevin
Spacey were Ozzie that that beast was
wrong but but also just be professor
Eck's about that just be professor Eck's
he's amazing he's amazing beat us on a
podcast just [ __ ] yeah I know yeah
we live in this [ __ ] Twitterverse
where they come after you over nothing
and you know I get it
I like that guy he's amazing magneto I
said Professor X I saw his bag I saw
this one Hanoi do a Shakespeare show but
it's College I think got to go backstage
and talk to him he's incredible what
else you got so a Tennessee man was
arrested for dipping his balls in
somebody's salsa because they left him I
believe is like 89-83 cent tip for
delivery that's cool and there's a video
of it oh [ __ ] let me see it
hold on Fort Lee is it a chunkier
Chipotle is it like a real like habanero
hot sauce I don't think it's habanero
it's probably something much milder it
doesn't seem chunky seems much more of
like a dip like water because of its
pico de gallo then it's really not a
video of him dipping his balls
Oh a post mate we don't know what the
actually it's I believe dinner delivery
was the app but what kind of savage tips
before they even deliver yes he also
that's how certain apps work that you've
got or some will give you the option to
tip right when you place the orders and
we'll give you the option to tip
afterwards always after yeah and I send
for a 30-minute Drive and it may not
have had been the person's intention of
tipping 89 cents it may have been the
preset tip percentage of whatever was
yours just like okay that guy isn't a
bad guy he's just being a [ __ ] silly
goose so [ __ ] it
yeah but now you know he is a bad guy
but if we could do that salsa you spa no
one is against you just dip it is I
think I gave you no tip I'll dip my
balls in your [ __ ] you know you think
that's okay it's better than firing all
the handicapped people like you want to
tune and play on a bad guy they didn't
come in not a bad guy actually pretty
cool I think says blame Jerry over here
godless he's fine you're wrong yeah it's
not a big deal up on the wrist you got
don't put your balls in people's food I
told you when I worked at a restaurant
the guy who was weird he was a busboy
and he had scar even cut in his face and
he was from somewhere and didn't speak
English very well and we caught him
she's I was like come over here and we
used to put the jellies into little
those little things on the tables you
know and he was licking all the jellies
all of them
that's when she goes to the guy the
other guy could can you tell him I don't
want to fight her he just can't like all
the johnnies I don't like to have you
seen the video that guy stirring I think
it's coffee with his dick at his work
no that's Google I heard YouTube that oh
yeah the guy who takes the coffee and
stirs it with his dick or piss isn't it
cuz he hate this co-workers now that's a
bad guy is it you sure he just man stirs
how about man pisses in coffee at work
that sounds familiar that's a problem
yeah he wouldn't start coffee cuz that
would really hurt are you crazy dude
yeah yes this one is it this one or this
one caught my camera peeing in the
coffee pot that sound
that's a weird perversion where you just
wanting or you just hate your coworkers
look at him drinking from the can like a
savage what a rebel what a rebel the
risk he's taking of someone walking in
on him right now
this - don't get my spit he just spit it
him huh nice piss on it cuz he hates his
co-workers he's really getting low he's
pissed damn he's going all out oh he's
guys he's mine he's lost his [ __ ]
mind what he lost his job but I saw I
could smell that pit listen I'm such a
coffee connoisseur I could smell pee pee
in my coffee you ain't fooling me with a
dark roast he's not doing well oh [ __ ]
no way
look at this [ __ ] oh you do just
this might be fade you you do just pour
it and take a sip
oh that's fake that's fake yeah looks
fake well it's embarrassing
let's keep you on you guys know I'm
talking about you've seen people pizza
employee cot pain in kitchen sink
who gives a thought a peon sinks all the
time
I love it matter of fact I feel like
thanks I feel like a Hells Angel when I
do it yeah
look man sometimes you gotta just piss
you know dude if there's if the bath is
blocked I'm pissing your scene well I've
taken shits like right outside
somebody's liking parking lots at door
I'm about [ __ ] but I love peeing
sinks since college my thing in college
man and I may have to ask me stop
painting sinks I shat right on near
someone's wheel do you talk about some
different you know [ __ ] in a club and I
went outside and I was like I'm gonna
take a [ __ ] there and I climbed over and
I took a [ __ ] and then he was Italian
and my friend said he said if you do it
again I'll kick you in the face I was
like well let him try I'm from New York
I said and I wasn't tell me who do you
want wrestler I said how many how many
times they BtoB Rudy one wrestler I
never said you were young I never said
that guarantee well I never say oh I say
is this I go well I went to it like
thing I was a wrestler you know that was
my sport the guy well you gotta go well
yeah I mean I went to a d1 school to
rest see myself I'm sure my spidey
senses don't think yeah but when I say
that if you are so yeah it's not true
because where we went to a deal remember
you had that friend he said he fought
yeah remember like beer knuckle I okay
let's look it up and they said he
wrestled at this very film school rap
friends who wrestled out yeah what hey
in there the same agent have you ever
heard this guy like never heard of them
and then I remember I asked me oh no I
was it on the team on I've come in to
help out well that doesn't programs
don't do that
they don't allow outsiders to come in
you know oh no especially at Arizona
State
well when I rest you have no background
wrestling they don't like to come in man
I wrestled at d1 school I allow people
made sense I like gaston's god I wish I
could hear you telling some girl the
rest of it Division one oh well you know
what I do say they say what happened is
my god I just watch so I say say ask me
if I do any age it's around dude any
combat sports me I spend so much my
childhood I'm at dude that's all is cuz
I did judo because technically I did you
know three years then I wrestled for
four years so you know it sounds good
though and I didn't even that's a
stretch
was like in college we had the stud
quarterback joke lat
he looked you know he's six there's a
handsome guy six-foot not big dumb
blonde kid but he burst on the scene and
we had a bar and this guy we're waiting
for a drink and the guys next to him
talking a girl and she's like I can't
believe you're drunk lat you threw for
400 yards in CSU's again kind of he's
like I'm kind of sore you know it's not
a big deal I like this girl's right
behind no I just go with it and the guys
talking and they're given free drinks I
think he's drunk latinum Joel thousand
sugars Joe glad honey guys again good to
see you but then when you turn on cm you
like oh [ __ ]
and guess what Joe glad to say anything
I do you think man yeah let him get laid
shut up guys dick sucked I mean I went
to a deist you know yeah wrestled I know
that was my sport no yes I went to ID
one school to Russ I mean as you know I
would have kind of made the team I hit
him with that I'll say stuff like that a
lot
ow my hand so Gracie blue belt so I say
that too
that works what else we got I do box I
like to spar you know what I mean I love
Sam about 52 I don't you guys called it
right yep
you'd have we've been on it my brother
so I'm not lying
the mountain lion was a they called a
kitten which is kind of messed up it was
I mean she called 24 pounds [ __ ] off
still don't do that Ken still messed him
up though no 24 pounds after it was
eaten no citizens necropsy said actually
after they looked at the whole thing the
kitten was a 24 pound animal and you
know I don't know him I think he took
that Kim's cloth he killed him went like
this mmhmm yeah
kills mountain lion three to four months
old gotta try that with a with a 250
pound mountain let's see what happens
it's your hair Brian its animal
scavenged after its death well these it
owes by siblings to make sense what that
that's what cats do bro mountain lions
do yeah yeah but I mean they're doing
the kitten thing for sure to make it
look worse right instead of saying cub
24 pounds still not tiny I mean 24 pound
it should have been like 30 or 40 though
that wasn't though
forty pound pitbull will [ __ ] you up oh
yeah did you see the video that pitbull
I posted eating the fence
oh yeah jeez that was freakin creepy
Zout run so fast
Jesus no thank you did you dog bite not
he cool touch yeah what us yet Jim we
talked about this woman before this
schoolteacher she is pretty hot she's so
hot right but the dude was 13 years old
sixth grade and they could see some of
her texts now would let the other boys
watch I mean this is a family she would
have a shows have one person watching to
make sure no one came in while they're
doing together Jen but she did this is
she must be completely crazy right she
got the text yeah I'm serious about the
you know check this off oh yeah what you
doing she says and he says thing about
your sex self because he's 13 she's aa
baby I wish you're with me video I want
you baby
when can wait [ __ ] yeah yeah I want
you to I want you to baby so bad
whenever we can you know I'm down so her
English isn't great as a teacher but
whatever that's the first round I have
sex her to me every day you like you for
real get sexy to me every day every day
ll and he puts I want to [ __ ] so bad
baby those times weren't enough for me
heart heart emoji she put me neither
baby I want you if she's got a real time
limb so there's a record of this the
same that's her touch this is this is a
person who needs psychological help
yeah she's got real problem no horrible
person well I mean but she's she's for
like crazy yeah she's not well dude you
know what she's gorgeous
but yeah and I'll post bail for ya she
we needed G's help yeah he's real half
shave and shave and she's real he'll get
a lunchbox needs real help right I mean
good stout hot she is
deal well she's just not well
something's wrong something's very wrong
grater
yep she's terrible she was married yeah
she was married at the time too
dude can you imagine being her husband
uh your wife is having an affair with a
13 year old your wedding hackers can't
be mad the 13 is she from another
country
no she's white okay well she got me from
milk up kick off your English isn't
greater but this is so weird man or also
[ __ ] look at that what that mouth do
girl hey man yes sir
I admit that I am turned on but still
all right look when I was searching for
- you know man - to help those lips rap
it out my oh my [ __ ] I've been texting
her at 13 maybe ever been boys even if I
House poised for such [ __ ] we're like
as we know it was like to be boys if
this was a groom we'd be like this
terrible oh girl boo boys you're like
whoa different man well the kid was fine
I guarantee the boys not traumatized
I'll tell ya be still have to have laws
but jeez you know when they have that
thing where when you're about to get
booked you're on video camera you have
to say whatever - they said that she
wants to go home to her husband that's
what she said right and this apartment
looks like she's in 60 days there now
how long they put her away for it's it's
not gonna be good or not sure yep you
can't get a job so yet to find a man who
pays your bills but I'm sure she'll be
fine I'm sure the Art Fair
meets psychological can't let's sort of
GoFundMe she needs psychological
counseling though you know I know she's
sexually assaulting thirteen-year-old
boy a hundred plus time so they had a
lot of sex they I'm sure consensual dude
at 13-13 busting a hundred loads with a
hot teacher
[Music]
dude just still just way too [ __ ]
young no you're you know what when
you're right right that's [ __ ] up
that's just simply for real - yonk tup
like this is a this is a crazy crazy
person you're talking about a sixth
grade
imagine at least let it get high school
ruff
stop being so cast it's great be more
outraged and she's small too she's small
she's pretty tiny I dude what the [ __ ]
is with you I know mama
I remember in sixth grade my teachers
were huge like maybe it's just cuz I was
small I remember just being like big I'm
rad this teacher in Missy sex is fine
right look she's small at top I'm a dad
this teacher named Miss Dekker I think
this is at Jimenez who needs
psychological serious psychological
health it looks like she needs dick
Brian
ah no that's what she wants she Chi this
is so weird
it's so [ __ ] weird he put you will be
my wife one day in this crazy life she
put I'll give you whatever you want baby
13 dude why they keep posting a picture
with her lips are all pouty like that
what the [ __ ] they drop right what are
you trying to say
she's a creme dude how about a 13 he put
I want you to be my wife
you know what this kid could be the
biggest player of all pieces yeah he's
not really honey dick in this crazy dumb
let me get caught I guess his parents
his parents found out that he said he
was dating someone and they found I was
his teacher like who no way
ya know I'd be like no [ __ ] way he's
my love would you tell on them right
away Brian I mean I'd like you know what
when you have a Peter uh Peter I don't
have a crazy person teacher confidence
now he's just out of her [ __ ] mind
dude she is out of her mind and you I
need you a little bit more out right now
and now this yet or my bro I'm with you
man I mean yeah this is great hey stop
being all like hey but what happens we
don't know what though I want to see
these kids I know it's [ __ ] up but I
think the kids might like you might be
six to like Judi grew up raise a buck
LeBron James like like you know looks
like Greg oh hey I need to see what the
kid looks like it's possible you know do
you he might be that kid in sixth grade
that has the long sideburns
I just behind of like when you're more
mature than ever
yeah that that happens you you're a
man-child you know but I I feel Chum
I've been [ __ ] bro I feel like it I
wish he was 16 then I can wahoo but 13 I
just can't get B I heard of one of the
witnesses like a kid just a voice it was
like a little kid I think that saw it
his friend do this so it sounded like a
little kid like I do it I mean look he's
13 though yeah
dude at 13 remember watching while
especially bad day I was watching fuzzy
porno now imagine if you had a hot
t-shirt teachers your best friends
railing her and your watch but also she
had it caught she has to know she's
getting caught so what's going on in her
head today this is a or she thought he
was 13 it's so outrageous she wouldn't
get caught because if she's crazy she's
not thinking like we are right she's
like oh I can go home I was thirsty no
gang a [ __ ] cause she's got miles of
text messages and notes hates it says
father confronts teacher you see that
chin ii went on the second row yeah
what's it father say father looks you
got a father looks weird well there's a
video dude what kind of [ __ ]
perverted person are you I want to know
right now
the father heard saying Britney has been
a great teacher for a long time five
years she's done so much for so many
students she made a huge mistake
turn $50,000 bond is there a video using
mistake this isn't more than a mistake
this is a suicide in a way this is a
crazy this is a crazy thing I don't know
what else man it's been D we've been
talking about child molestation
know what this chef oh good god
ariana grande and Big Sean got together
are they back together they're spotted
together suppose goes yeah the fattest
[ __ ]
really it sounds really creepy cuz my
voice is like this but apparently that's
what I can't beat Shawn cuz he's a small
man small man with him with a real piece
congratulation and he put the rapper
embarrassed her with his billion-dollar
[ __ ] lyric yeah well do see Pete
Davidson has a new girl too it's the
same one right
no dude he was dating a grande now he's
dating Kate Beckett yeah we didn't talk
about that and they were well there's
pictures of them sucking faith she's
older yeah I saw it at a party though
drop-dead gorgeous yeah breathtaking how
old is she though she's 46 on the ship
you know well that 45 well Pete's my
Pete's 25 hmm she's gorgeous they're
welcome sucking face he's got down well
they aren't going aah aah
just [ __ ] licking each other man
they're in love you know Pete get some
hoes Andy yeah he's got them tats well
the one behind his ears ariana grande's
that's awkward
you covered it up and made it into a
heart okay good for him I'll get them
just he's just going full tongue yeah
what else you guys got this one people
are saying this is a really creepy video
for a hotel and this guy grabbing Malik
is promoting a hotel I live here was it
weird you saw it why is he what is he
doing hotels who knows because I paying
five I'm a fan of Freddie Mercury and
Queen I'm a fan of my mom she's got my
back I'm a fan of camomile tea
[ __ ] off I'm a fan of handwritten
letters I hold kid thoughtful you out of
my face I'm a fan of classic movies I'm
a fan of looking sharp regardless of the
occasion pretty each brother I'm a fan
of random encounters hate that I'm a fan
of travelling by train hate that I'm a
fan of equal opportunities for all
[ __ ] now I'm a fan of mischief
get the [ __ ] are we robbing banks
well fan being exactly who I want to be
that means nothing
I'm a fan of Mandarin Oriental wow it's
a high that's a high-end hotel yeah they
said it sound like a serial killer he
said look Bundy he's a weirdo yeah he's
a strange cat uh yeah how would your
commercial go my golly
would your I'm a fan of coffee I'm a fan
I'm a fan of get my dick sucked I'm
gonna fan of having the handicap fired
when I've done fan of blaming somebody
who can't defend in a time of need
oh I'm a fan of reading magazines while
I'm taking shirts and eating candy and
then blaming Jerry for what I did
because I can and it doesn't really
matter if he has that job or not let's
be honest I'm a fan of good and massage
parlors and hoping it's a happy end yep
Van Damme mischief I'm a fan of mischief
a fan of professionals fan of raw doggin
and Romo fails busting nuts yep I'm a
fan of having my friend milk my nut sack
no reason I'm a fan of greeting my
friend at the door in a robe and going
whoops having my fully erect dong I'm
gonna say hello sucking man I'm a fan
I'm a fan alright God you could do that
yeah right now tricks dad he says he
supports our Kelly
a hundred percent and he believes
justice Smollett I'm sorry why are we
talking about trachs dad who gives up I
thought what are like he must be like in
the spotlight because if he definitely
buddies wants to be and here's the
here's the bummer came out with his own
rap album I loved his son so he's a
complete son and he estranged they were
yeah I think Drake grew up with just his
mom ah there you go there are better
terms no now they're better right mm-hmm
I'm not a fan of Drake's dad I'm not a
fan of Drake's daddy I'm not a fan of
guys
who are in their 50s 60s and 70s who
wear a bandana and then a hat over that
bandana sparkly and bows out Johnny Depp
yes a mouthful not a fan of mustaches
that size of Robin Revere a statue that
wash my car it would keep him warm in
the wintertime my fan of his gold chains
I'm a fan of him he probably gives girls
good broom service move that [ __ ]
mustache I bet he dicks girls down here
take it now what else we got this here
just one more yeah um darn it let me see
all right two more for you if they're
good all right so this is what Darren
till posted it's about a Russian woman
who knocked this dude out that was
bullying another guy I'd have yes he
does she [ __ ] yeah this guy this is
like luck but this is like to 2016 or
something yeah but Russia just get it
now you know watch this
check it out it's the girl that works a
little shop this girl on [ __ ] you la
bride look that one does this one look
this one do you ready for this boom a
little girl dude she just knocked that
[ __ ] out and then the guy and
the and then she goes behind the counter
he shakes her hand that's Russia America
Oh y'all just honks they're all thumbs
Russians I love her a Russian they they
do it right they do what we do Ben I
like I live there I rush in my little my
friend Terrence told ray people I eat
out there they said they're the greatest
people who live there car broke down
everybody come out and help they're
awesome yeah go live there I'm olive
there it wouldn't be bad not living
rough I'm live in Moscow you would not
you don't know me you don't know me full
of [ __ ] or the fan of Russia and I know
Santa Oscar right this is the last one
someone just tagged you guys on this one
so the Arnold Schwarzenegger
that's the Arnold Classic a classic yep
well then you guys talked about
chocolate bodies this is super chocolate
buddy Jesus Christ we got a tan up dude
Arnold doing a self as you want to
believe damn race you won that's a 2-1
the forehead
just to the girl on the left is actual
chocolate muddy the girl in the middle
is not the girl on the right is not girl
the Reyes that takes a lot exotic yeah
that's natural right yeah all of them
don't touch steroids I'm a fan of girls
with dicks
I'm a fan of tanning none stopped you
become black really really thin skin
paper-thin skin I would they don't stink
at all what does that smell that why the
all they do is consume protein and
tilapia spray their body with paint
they smell like [ __ ] that's not that's
not good their hair is fried I just
don't think they look good when they do
that I just don't just do dot I mean I
don't think it's good like everyone on
earth I like Fitness competitors I bet
you do
bring up some Fitness please don't
please don't let's I gotta in the same
you go alright your voice you losing
your voice
you gotta go do a new road you know
three hours bring your look at me I'm
gonna teach you a voice lesson right
we've done this it doesn't help ring I
can hear y'all I know you hell riot your
you give me the worst advice right now
right doesn't work do it
b-but are you on the road again this
weekend I'm gonna be at the make-a-wish
Foundation I'm doing Cobbs San Francisco
one night only for the make-a-wish in
Saturday Thursday March 14th then I'll
be at the Kansas City improv March 22nd
and 23rd Philadelphia March 28th 29th
and 30th it's gonna be buying tickets
it's both can be gone I'm back on the
road starting next week Friday Saturday
two shows Friday to show Saturday Miami
improv Miami it's also my birthday
weekend we bout to be weird
we're bout to you wild we bout to have
fun Miami Miami improv March 15th and
16th that's next Friday Saturday those
shows almost sold out the Milwaukee
Turner hall Turner hall Milwaukee the
wheat fall in week March 22nd through
23rd one night Friday one show Saturday
and then Washington DC end of the month
DC improv March 20th 30th get tickets
now to fat K da home that it be that's
it buddy
alright man well I think you're sharing
your story about being molested sure
this is the bottom kid for out